hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar an introduction to liquid
chromatography mass spectrometry for the
clinical laboratory I am Antonina
Saucedo of lab routes and I will be your
moderator for today's events today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes and is made possible by an
educational grant from Agilent let's get
started before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits tab
located in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. Adam J
McShane from Cleveland Clinic doctor
McShane obtained his PhD in biological
chemistry at the University of
Connecticut and completed his clinical
biochemistry fellowship at Cleveland
Clinic he currently served at Cleveland
Clinic as a medical director of the
automated chemistry laboratory and
toxicology and proteomics specialists in
the chemistry laboratory and as
associate director of the clinical
biochemistry fellowship program dr.
McShane is a diplomat of the American
Board of clinical chemistry and an
Associate Fellow of the AACC Academy for
a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr. McShane you may now begin your
presentation well thank you very much
for the introduction and thank you for
inviting me today to speak I'm probably
one of my favorite subjects to speak
about legal chromatography mass
spectrometry
treat and thank you to the audience for
joining us today and let me wish you the
happiest of April Fool's days I guess
you
so today we're going to touch on four
different portions we're going to talk
about the fundamentals of liquid
chromatography for the for the beginner
then move on to the fundamentals of mass
spectrometry some examples of why LC
mass spec is important for the clinical
laboratory and then finally we're gonna
have an example of a LC Mass Effect
clinical validation
so some of you may be familiar with
chromatography from back in your
undergraduate or graduate days I
remember we performed a forensic type of
experiment where we'd have different
pens and then the the pen of the person
who wrote the ransom notes was we're
trying to decipher in this experiment we
were putting a dab or writing on the
piece of paper with the three different
pens and then placing them into a
solvent system so solvent would wick up
the paper and then you would see the
black pens would then break down or
fractionate into their positions of the
colors that made the black ink and then
you could be able to pinpoint what pen
was used by you know the kidnapper for
example another example as seen here is
column chromatography often used in
organic chemistry here we have depicted
in a a glass column filled with silica
silica here is representing a stationary
phase much like the paper for the pen
experiment this phase does not move
once the analytes of interest is loaded
here is seen as the purple color a
mobile phase is introduced for liquid
chromatography the mobile phase is
liquid of course if you change the
mobile phase to gas as the carrier then
you're doing gas chromatography the
malla phase is introduced at the top of
a column you have a differential
partitioning between the mobile phase
and the stationary phase hopefully to
reveal that the purple ingredients is
made of blue and red as it seemed to
develop and B and C finally achieve
separation in feet collecting the red
portion in E and the blue portion and F
and the clinical laboratory we we don't
perform no column chromatography maybe
some labs or some glads used to perform
thin layer chromatography similar to the
pen and paper experiment but we're
helping with machines to get the
separation we need so we have liquid
chromatography here on the Left it uses
large diameter of stationary phase or
particles which does not require much
pressure to force the mobile phase
through the stationary phase to the
right of that you have high-performance
liquid chromatography here the particles
are much smaller about 3 to 5 micron and
the pressure need is to force the liquid
or mobile phase through this stationary
phase is much greater due to health how
fine the particles are this requires
specialized pumps which increases your
cost finally to the right you have ultra
performance liquid chromatography this
often uses sub 2 micron particles thus
demanding pump ii achieve very high
pressure around 14,000 pounds per square
inch and do these special pump sir 2
pumps designed for high pressure ii of
an increased costs
due to the much smaller particle size
you increased your resolution that you
are able to achieve in the same amount
of time by resolution we're talking
about the ability to resolve your
analyze of interest and depiction a you
see that there are critical pair I'm not
baseline separated and finally in
depiction see you can see that their
baseline separated from each other so
the ultra formance liquid chromatograph
can achieve a much higher resolution and
a much slimmer or lower time plus its
power of doing high performance or a
performance layer chromatography because
we are demanding of doing many samples
Nicole clinical laboratory or have the
demand of time upon us
so for the components of a
high-performance of liquid chromatograph
we have our mobile phase depicted here
and with the HPLC solvent you have the
stationary phase in the middle of the
picture with the HPLC column in order to
force these solvents through the column
via the HTF HPLC pump
if you're using a single solvent system
that's an ISO pratik method oftentimes
in a cold laboratory where you're using
at least two solvents but creating a
binary system we need to introduce your
sample into the flow path of the mobile
phase to go through the stationary phase
so you have an injector where often a
switching valve is utilized to introduce
your sample into the flow path finally
after eight elutes from the column you
need a way to detect the compounds of
interest coming off that is a link to a
kumkum computational system for the data
analysis and the specimen itself is end
gone to waste
now this can become more and more
complex
you could add on multiple pumps as we
discuss with binary systems where you
have multiple mobile phases and you have
multiple columns to achieve potentially
the sensitivity or specificity that you
need nothing goes through this this is
an example of one pump in our one pump
system in our laboratory where you can
see there's multiple injectors multiple
switching valves multiple columns on
different systems on this LC to achieve
different methods that that you can eat
so it can get much more complicated than
the simple depiction
so what is inside these columns what is
the column chemistry all the way to the
left you can see a normal phase column
chemistry this utilizes a polar
stationary phase a silica for example
with a nonpolar mobile phase such as
movie hexanes reverse phase is the
opposite of normal phase now the
stationary phase is no longer polar it
is nonpolar and the mobile phase is an
increasing from polar to nonpolar an
exchange utilizes one of the fundamental
principles of chemistry like part like
charges repel opposite charges attract
so your stationary phase is charged
where the mobile phase is the opposite
charge of the stationary phase finally
you have size exclusion so we can
imagine as an example where you had a
race and a busy hallway in your hospital
or laboratory won the race is between
you alone and the other group is a four
of your favorite laboratory mates that
are all holding hands and you ask them
who could reach the end of the hall
first the one acting alone or the one
linked with four hands you can see the
figure you are you might have difficulty
transversing
so in the clinical laboratory one of the
most common call encounters you callin
chemistry's utilizes reverse phase
but very briefly diving into this on
what is the polar and nonpolar phases
utilized for versus liquid
chromatography
here we see Pauling electricity chart on
the periodic table
fluorine all the way on top writes as
the highest electronegativity it
desperately wants to be like the noble
gas to the right of it neon juxtaposed
to this all the way to the left of
fluorine ooh of lithium lithium has a
low electronegativity meaning that it
would like to give up one of his
electrons to look like its partner no
law gas helium so you can have an
unequal sharing of electrons and since
electrons are negatively charged you can
create polarity for example here we have
water a very popular polar mobile phase
oxygen is represented represented in red
and hydrogen is represented in white so
if you look at the Pauling
electronegativity you can see that
there's a 1.4 difference between the
oxygen hydrogen atoms meaning oxygen has
a higher elective 'ti than hydrogen
we've an unequal sharing of electrons or
that negative charge because of this you
have a partial negative charge on the
oxygen and partial positive charges on
the hydrogen you can now draw a pole
from plus to minus we're going from the
bottom of the screen to the top of the
screen plus creating the polarity
opposite of this is nonpolar compounds
so here we have a carbon-carbon bond
they both have the same
electronegativity meaning there's no
difference between them and now you are
unable to draw a pole of positive or
negative because there is no difference
between the two so this is a non-polar
compound common examples to think of
this would be oil and water for example
so how do we utilize this in our column
chemistry's so depicted here we have the
inside of a column on the bottom we have
a C 18 carbon carbon chain this is a
column call excuse me this is a common
column chemistry that's utilized as a
non polar stationary phase as the mobile
phase we have water which is polar our
two compounds of interest are depicted
here as a and B and if they have any
hydrophobic characteristics comes a lot
of interactions with the c18 stationary
phase after loading we then ramp the
nonpolar solvent from mostly water to
mostly non polar such as a C nitrile or
methanol the hope is that you have a
differential reinter action between the
mobile phase and stationary phase with a
and B so they separate at different
times because they have different
periods or they like to be in a certain
percentage of nonpolar mobile phase
and here in the final cartoon this is
depicted as be has alluded first it is
more hydrophilic or water-loving than a
because is come off with a lower
percentage of nonpolar as addicted here
as percent B B being the strong solvents
in the binary solvent system and a being
the weak solvent which is water a is
more hydrophobic than be coming out
later requiring a higher percent B but
we have achieved baseline separation
between the two so an important facet of
live chromatography is that we have to
be able to detect what is eluding from
our column these are broken down into
two domains one being non-destructive
this in theory means you could collect
what alludes from the column again and
then not us not destroying it a common
example is UV vis or a spectrophotometer
is utilized and if you want the eluent
can be collected again destructive of
detectors this is unable to retrieve the
specimen aster is introduced into the
detector we are highlighting mass
spectrometry today once the analyte has
entered the mass spectrometer it is
unable to be retrieved but it is
destructive
so with that let's talk about the other
component of our hyphenated system of
lcms back to mass spectrometer
the mass spectrometer measures our
analyzes ions by their masks charge
ratio this sentence is packed with a lot
of information it's very important to
the methodology first it measures or
analyzes ions so you have to be ionized
in order to be measured by mass defect
to have a charge associate so she ate
with the analyte of interest second is
actually measuring their mass to charge
ratio so what is that the below we have
an example of a very simple mass to
charge ratio on the Left we have a
hydrogen atom the hydrogen atom has one
proton which has a positive charge and
one electrons that has a negative charge
plus one minus one is zero so there's no
net charge further the weight of a
hydrogen atom is one Dalton coming from
the proton the electron adds a very
significant amount of mass on the right
if we remove the electron then we still
have the Dalton's
one dolphin but we have a positive
charge with no cancelling negative
charge so the mass of the proton is plus
one divided by the charge which is one
therefore the mass to charge ratio of
this proton is one
so let's have an example for the
audience we have phenylalanine depicted
here on the left it has a mass of 165
Dalton's if I were to introduce this
into an acidic solution I could possibly
protonate the amine to become nh3
therefore carrying a positive charge and
also carrying one more hydrogen atom
if I add another Dalton to the mass I
get 165 plus 1 which equals 166 and the
charge is 1 for the one positive charge
on the nitrogen so 166 divided by 1 is
166 so the mass charge ratio
phenylalanine is 166
so what is inside this mass spectrometer
mass spectrometer consists of three main
components first be an ion source as
stated earlier you have to be an ion to
be analyzed by mass spectrometer so this
area you have the creation of ions for
the method second you have a mass
analyzer a mass analyzer needs to
separate the analytes of interest by
their mass to charge ratio and so
therefore they hit the detector
differentially and the detector is what
is producing your signal at the end of
the components the detector is hooked up
to a computer where you're on the
analysis performed to get your signal
and all this is under vacuum
I often use the analogy of building a
mass spectrometer to buying a car
depending on what type of car you want
to have you would pick out the different
one from the lot for example if you're
hauling a large family maybe you'd once
a minivan the minivan could have large
doors on the side to get everybody in
and out and many seats or if you're
hauling a trailer that's very heavy you
would want to truck it does does not
need to have capacity for people but you
wouldn't want to have maybe a large
engine so you'd have the towing power
needed for the trailer for a mass
spectrometer what you build is depending
on what you're intending to measure many
of you are might be familiar in the
microbiology world they use multi top
some matrix-assisted laser desorption
ionization as the ion source coupled
with a mass analyzer of time-of-flight
often in the clinical chemistry world we
are using ESI coupled to a quadrupole to
es eyes electrospray ionisation this
technique has the repulsion of analyzed
based on similar charges
hopefully removing solvents and
introducing them into the gas phase into
the quadrupole the quadrupole is the
mass analyzer used and often this is
coupled with an MCP or electron
multipliers and for this sector
further we can add additional components
here depicted you have a triple
quadrupole mass spectrometer plus called
because it has three quadruples two of
them analyzing and one not as if it is
one two and three to work your way
through the instrument first we have the
introduction of the sample coming off
your liquid chromatograph here enters
the ESI electrospray ionization source
where there is a differential voltage
utilized in order to introduce the
analyzed into the gas phase and q1 q1 is
a filtering quadrupole so a single mass
of charge can be selected bus depicted
here by a small blue dot and we filtered
out the other analytes this blue dot is
then introduced into the second
quadrupole where it does not filter but
is a collision cell the analytes of
interest is collided against an inert
gas such as nitrogen or argon to break
into fragments the fragments are then
introduced into the third quadrupole
which once again is a filtering step
here we have depicted a blue triangle
ultimately this will be allowed to pass
through the four third quadrupole and
hit the detector producing the signal so
many things going on here one is that
you need to be a blue dot that breaks
them to a blue triangle plus increasing
your analyte specificity that you have
you can add multiple fragments instead
of just a blue triangle you can have a
blue triangle and a pacman that need to
exist and these two can be a different
ratios of each other but two-to-one and
that can be monitored for the potential
of an analyte that's not your analyte of
interest all in all this is called
multiple reaction monitoring or
monitoring multiple reactions of q1
breaking into a triangle and the blue
dot for example breaking into the
pac-man
it's very powerful for us in the
clinical laboratory
as an example of fragmentation we have
phenylalanine again breaking into four
different components so for the
precursor ion the one that is filtered
in q1 you could have the mass-to-charge
ratio of phenylalanine four then for q3
you could select one or up to four
different compounds or fragment ions to
be measured
briefly we'll talk about ylc mass spec
or this technique we briefly touched
upon previously is important to the
clinical laboratory
you know essays are often usable
utilized in the clinical laboratory but
they have several drawbacks
here depicted on the left you can see we
have a blue antibody connected to
potentially a pair of magnetic bead that
a magnet could be used to help collected
and then the green antibody potentially
has some sort of signal producing
substance on an enzyme for example or
maybe a compound that glows or
fluoresces in order to complete a you
know metric or sandwich immunoassay you
need to have the compound of interest
connecting these two antibodies here we
can see we have a antibody to the
compound of interest but shielding it
from the sandwich assay causing falsely
low results
the opposite of this is called bridging
we have a heterophile antibody that has
interaction with the to capture
antibodies shown for the sandwich si bus
causing a falsely high results and
oftentimes use for small molecules we
have competitive immunoassays we are
unable to use a sandwich or muna metric
si because we have steric hindrance the
molecule is just too small to get two
antibodies epitope recognitions so here
we use a competitive assay with an
analyte of interest that has a tag on it
for example fluorescence we have the
interaction or competition of these two
they both be endogenous and the one in
the reagents between the antibody so if
the signal is very high that means there
is low amounts of you doggedness
compound conversely if the signal is
very low that means there is high
amounts of the endogenous compounds some
of the pitfalls for this is that since
it only has one epitope recognition site
the specificity of the antibody can
Susser do you adjust the size of the
molecule causing essentially low or
unable to reach low levels of
sensitivity for measurement or getting
many false results
here conversely we look at advantages of
the LC mass spec methodology mainly is
the increased specificity so knowing
what you're measuring is what you're
measuring we have many quality
measurements within a LC mass spec
methodology that all need to be positive
in order to produce the signal for
example the retention time if you build
an assay and you have a you know it
alludes between 0.8 and 1 minutes you
can always measure that and if it's
outside that window it's not your
compound of interest you have an
internal standard that can be all added
when internal standard is often an
isotopic I labeled analogue of your
analyte of interest may be replacing the
carbons with carbon 13 or replacing the
hydrogen deuterium atoms this should
have very similar characteristics with
LC mass spec methodology and have
similar it's not the same retention
times
also you can modern multiple transitions
which we mentioned earlier with the blue
dot breaking into a potentially
rectangle and a pacman can be monitored
with this you can monitor the ion ratio
between those two to ensure that they
are meeting what you've seen in
validation it's always a two to one
ratio and it's suddenly a 100 to 1 ratio
this cue alarm lets not your analyte of
interest because the internal standard
ion abundance your internal standard is
added at the same amount for all of your
analytes of interest and calibrators so
seeing a doubling tripling or
quadrupling of this can be a sign that
there may be and there fear with your
internal standard and finally you have
the chromatography the chromatography
can be reviewed for peak tailing peak
fronting split Peaks multiple Peaks
alluding eventually causing interference
with your measurements which can be
reviewed all of these are viewable
versus a immunoassay essentially where
you may be able to see a reaction
monitor but ultimately you're just
producing a signal from a secondary
interaction with the antibodies one
example of its strength is seen here
with two immunosuppressants the
immunosuppressants as depicted on the
right are quite similar in structure
many antibody based tests can have
difficulty differentiating between the
two with LC only you can see that the
two peaks allude exactly the same
however since they have different master
charge ratios they can be easily
distinguished with an LC mass spec mass
spec methodology
next we're going to talk about an
example of an LC Mass Effect clinical
validation
[Music]
the example we're going to be using is
trial and by fungal drugs depicted here
we have five trial medications
Buchanan's electric on valve or cons
well post console a nice Abud Kaunas all
on Menaul has different antifungal
activities to the species listed these
medications are important for invasive
fungal infections which can be deadly
for immunosuppressed populations such as
transplant patients
if you you're in your hospital has
decided that this is important because
you have a large transplant population
and the turnaround time that needed to
adjust those two days is not being
achieved by reference laboratories you
can bring this method into your lab if
you decided to do to sell a review of
the literature shows different
methodologies available you have the bio
assays which take almost a day to
complete a very low analyte specificity
meaning knowing what you're measuring a
little sensitivity meaning how well you
can measure you're measuring range which
is how low to high you can measure and
multiplexing meaning can you measure
more than one analyte at a time
LC alone is an hour approximately has
better analyze specificity and
sensitivity a great measuring range and
you can measure more than one tries all
at a time finally at the bottom LC mass
spec Mass Effect by multiple reaction
monitoring have the lowest time the best
specificity and sensitivity a great
measuring range and can multiplex so
decision could be made to move forward
with LC mass spec mass spec methodology
which is best for your laboratory
so we need to develop the method so here
very briefly we have 50 microliters of
the patient's serum or plasma the
protein are precipitated using a acidic
acid notch out solution the precipitate
is centrifuge the supernatant is taken
and then diluted with our mobile phase a
and then introduced into the LC mass
spec mass spec and we're using the
following LC and triple quadrupole mass
spectrometer from thermo
chromatography is depicted here be is
the strong solvents so ramping from 40%
to 60% before collaborating these are
quite hydrophobic compounds we're using
the c18 column which is depicted earlier
about a 5 centimeter length 2.1 diameter
and the diameter of the particles is 2.6
micron solvent a is acidified water
solvent B is acidified C nitrile so the
polar nonpolar mobile phases the flow
rate is point 8 mils per minute and here
is an example of a chromatography of the
five analytes plus hydroxy etre Kanazawa
chizz metabolites of a Chicanos all
so once you have your developed method
you've done all your prevail adacia murk
and you feel comfortable moving forward
with the establishment of this method we
can look to our regulators from CLIA it
requires us to establish the following
seven characteristics accuracy precision
analytical sensitivity and with
specificity
there were portable range to reference
interval and finally any other
performance characteristic required for
the test we can think of this as kind of
a catch-all on one common example I'll
utilizes stability of course you know
how long from draw to analysis you can
wait before you have degradation of the
compound
so for experimenting specifics there's
much not much listed listed in the Clio
law however you can look at FDA
guidelines for IV DS clsi guidelines
these are consensus based on guidelines
on different areas in the laboratory and
then the medical director or director of
the laboratory is over the tests before
starting a validation experiment we want
to make sure that we have a strong pre
validation protocol so with this we list
the details upper in regards to what
experiments we want to perform on the
ranges we want to measure the different
matrices for example the material we're
going to use
we have the acceptability criteria of
what a failing or passing experiment
looks like and then ultimately any
signature or standard deviation from
this requires a director signature the
validations experiments typically
perform for LCM aspect
validation include ion suppression which
we'll talk about in a moment a mixing
study interferences the reportable range
carryover stability precision method
comparison and reference interval for
this presentation I'll just focus on one
weiss Buchanan's all which is the
analyte that comes from the pro drug is
listed here it was recently brought
through FDA in March of 2015 most five
years ago for the treatment of these two
invasive fungal infections
the first experiment is ion suppression
fine suppression is the phenomenon with
LC mass spec methods in a perfect world
your analyte would be the only thing
eluding from the LC column and being
introduced into the ion source
unfortunately this is a foreground and
possibility will be many other analyzed
even if they're not direct interference
diluting at the same time from the
liquid chromatograph if they're in high
enough abundance they can compete for
the ionization of your analyte of
interest or leaving the liquid phase
entering the gas phase and ayane
mediators from the q1 to assess if this
is happening we utilize the post column
confusion experiment it's one of two
common experiments used to assess this
at the very top we have the LC pump the
injector and column and then the ion
source here we're introducing patients
that are free of eisah buchanan's all
updated and extracted and ready for the
method in the bottom we have a syringe
pump which is being peed into the post
column here we're constantly infusing a
solution of isoloop Kaunas all
the bottom depicts on the the experiment
the blue line is a patient excuse me a
matrix that is a blank such as a solvent
that's being injected in a perfect world
all of your patient samples look exactly
look exactly like your blue line that's
depicted unfortunately you can see that
many of the black lines of excusing all
the black lines are having a suppression
around the very front of the method this
is due to many hydrophilic compounds
alluding off the column having no
interaction of the c18 hydrophobic phase
if I sebou Kaunas all were to elute
around the point two minute mark it
would experience ion suppression the
lever
I salute causes all is alluding around
the bard blue lines around one point one
here you can see that the black lines
and blue lines are intertwined and we
have a depiction of 20% up and down from
there meaning as well within the know
ions oppression is seen or I an
enhancement which can be seen in very
rare cases next we have a mixing study
this is to determine a candidate matrix
we chose charcoal strip serum this is
commercially available and easy for us
to obtain we did mixing between our
sample matrix serum and plasma and this
charcoal strip serum with different
levels of izu comas all and different
ratios of the mixture the theoretical
should match the experimental two
matrices or equal not the experiment was
performed because the difference between
the two was about 5%
next we have analytical specificity
first we evaluated endogenous
interferences common to the clinical
laboratory such as like Kimia hemolysis
and icterus this was evaluated to ICU
console concentrations 1 and 6 and they
were mixed with patient samples or
store-bought smallest actress or
leukemia to see if there's a difference
between the two after they are mixed
together from the theoretical to the
measure concentration at the low levels
Weiss Buchanan's all they all match
within 10 percent or 0.1 my grams per
milliliter at the high level of lives of
UConn is all they're all less than 5
percent difference from each other next
we have interferences from exhaustive
sources we looked at common therapeutic
drugs um what you want to do when you
evaluate a local specificity frame
medicine such as ice abou comas all or
any other analyte is look for isobars
isobars are medications that may have
the same mass as your analyte of
interest if it has the same mass it may
have the same mass to charge ratio it
may have a similar illusion may have
similar fragment ions and the fragment
ions may have similar ratios if all
those criterias are met you can have an
interference or a false positive result
with your methods
here we have the reportable range and
analytical sensitivity we purchased
traceable I Cebu Kaunas all that was
spiked in at known concentrations and a
recovery experiment was performed you
can also perform limit of blank limited
section little quant Asian experiments
where you have no eyes of you Kaunas all
and a patient sample or eyes of you
Kaunas all levels at the detection and
quantitation where they are ran or
analyzed at multiple time points to
determine their variance and precision
here we establishing zero point two to
ten micrograms per milliliter range of
observable error less than five percent
carryover is another catch-all item as
in number seven with their clear
regulations and also with some of our
other regulators such as cat multiple
ways reform carry over here is a very
simple demonstration of analyzing a low
concentration followed by an absurdly
high concentration that you would
hopefully never observe in a real
patient sample followed by the low
concentration again the means of the low
concentration should match the means of
the low concentration prior to the high
concentration being analyzed which is
seen here with no difference
ability is another needed item to
stability studies were performed one is
the UH next racket so CRM or Plasma that
was left at room temperature
refrigerated or frozen the other
extracted so this is a sample that's
been prepared the proteins have been
precipitated it's been diluted with
mobile phase a and ready for analysis
this is important for extractions that
may be longer that these precious
samples may have to sit because there's
instrument with your LCM aspect machine
so here we establish that seven days
these we left refrigerated without the
need for extraction of the original
patient sample and may or may not be
available in the cartoon you have the
three levels that we chose and the hope
is that at the end of your time frame it
will match the beginning at day zero
precision we performed this clsi
experiments where mid high and low
samples I ran in this order twice a day
for five days there are multiple ways to
perform precision such as running your
samples once a day for twenty days
the means of the three levels we chose
are here as well as they're within run
so that's the same a say without the
debris extraction and then total which
is a combination of the within run and
then the multiple days analysis all
having CV is less than 3%
accuracy was evaluated with our
traceable standards but it's also
evaluated with a comparator laboratory
which is a cap requirement they perform
at least 20 samples here 40 samples were
shared with a comparator laboratory they
do not have an exact method but a
similar method we had a slope of 0.996
perfect would be one intercept to zero
point one one five perfect would be zero
an R zero point nine nine to seven we're
perfect is one and the difference
between these two methods although stays
away was less than four percent
the reference intervals so obviously a
normal reference interval as you think
of with calcium for example you couldn't
take 120 healthy individuals and run ISO
Buchanan's all because healthy
individuals wouldn't be on an antifungal
medication so here we can look at what
our therapeutic or prophylactic levels
in literature from large trial studies
or from societies such as the infectious
disease Society of America shown here
where you can establish proper ranges
for your method
thank you for listening I just have a
couple of key takeaways after our
validation study one is that the
hyphenated method of lc-ms that is
excellent for a light sensitivity and
specificity if you design a proper assay
secondly due to this
excellent analyst analytes in saving
specificity this would be a very
powerful tool for the clinical
laboratory for a better method that
doesn't it that that may be out there or
to a method that may not even exist
thank you very much for for listening
today and with that I'd love to take any
questions
McShane for your informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
let's get started
our first question is besides
small-molecule an analyst is lc/ms
useful for larger analytes
well that's a great question Elsie mass
spec has found of home and small
molecule analysis however recent
advancements in the last 10 to 15 years
have seen this move into the larger
molecule world such as proteomics you
can see different methodologies being
utilized as a survival and in reference
laboratories subtyping amyloids
basically these proteins are broken into
peptides and then analyzed or with the
power of different mass spectrometers
that are the ability to have high
resolution you have an act intact
analysis of proteins so a very exciting
field that's emerging for a decade or
two
great um our next question is what are
the hurdles to lc-ms implementation
yes so if you don't already have this
system you have the upfront costs of
buying one then of course it utilizes
different gases that you would need such
as new nitrogen or argon so that would
have to be baza or piped in although
there is movements into holy
fda-approved devices many analyzer
unavailable so you need the expertise to
develop and validate these assays and
also keep them running in robust
thank you doctor machine so we're going
to wrap up with this final question it
is what are some common issues seen with
routine MS testing
I would say one of those common issues
after a method is validated you're
running for clinical purposes is issue
the sensitivity this can be monitored
with different mixtures of your analytes
of interest such as ices of Carnival and
a solvent system to see if the recovery
of the instrument is not behaving that
day whether it be from potential
dirtiness in the Front's at the orifices
such as between the ion source of q1
potentially a failing vacuum so you're
not removing the other atmospheric gas
in the air so I would say that was
probably one of the most common issues
we see this little sensitivity on the
mass spectrometer
other great questions thank you again
dr. Machine for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots in our educational
sponsor Agilent for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of your registration this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
April of 2021 lab routes will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events until next time
goodbye